the portal between mind and awareness
mind is like the clouds
the transient appearances of thoughts
emotions feelings perceptions
sensations beliefs
in the sky in which the clouds
happen is the awareness
creating this very simple juxtaposition
enables us to transcend the mind and to
recognize the eternal
shared sky the observer the
witness the god-realized state
and in doing so it brings us the peace
and happiness of the diamond necklace
that is already around our necks
and then we recognize that those clouds
are not something for us to get
obsessive
about we don't have cravings for clouds
we don't try and avert clouds
they're just simply what appears
on the sky
of awareness
once you recognize that clouds appear in
the sky of awareness
you gain a sense of eternal peace and
happiness
you recognize the transients of the
clouds
this is the portal that we talk about
the very simple juxtaposition
and the analogy here that we're using
is one that is a common perennial
wisdom across the mystic traditions
where you juxtapose the clouds and the
sky
ultimately this is one but we create
this dualistic
juxtaposition as a concession in order
to make it easier for people to
portal away from the egoic finite
separate contracted energy of the mind
towards the eternal the infinite sky
the awareness that is being
colored by the experience of these
clouds in these creation designs that we
dream
and rupert spyra has been a big
influence on us here as well
with again a very simple analogy
the pure bare empty awareness of the sky
is just like these sheets of paper that
are
pure bare and empty blank
but they are eternally being colored in
these
creation designs by experience
which in this case is like
the words over here so
my awareness can be colored by words
meanwhile
your awareness over here can be colored
by art
but it's the same witness the same
observer the same god the same awareness
that is being colored uniquely by
in this case words in this case art
another very simple analogy
is the i the i you have the pupil
the pupil is the eternal shared
awareness that is god that's what we
share among us is the pupil the witness
the observer
while the iris is the unique coloration
of each expression of the infinite
we all have the diamond around our necks
each one of us that's the pupil
but the diamond slash the jewel refracts
the source light in the unique way
that's the
iris that's why there's the
artistic color palette where
each one of us is a unique expression
contributing a unique
gift that's why this unit has a very
specific
identifiers and those units out there
the audience's units have their own
unique identifiers when you shed
all of those identifiers the onion
layers
what you get to is you get to the exact
same source the exact same infinitive
the exact same
god realization the exact same pupil
witness
observer when you add the onion layers
of identity what you get is the unique
artistic expression
that's why i run this simulation
enlightenment media company as an
expression of the infinite
meanwhile you might be an engineer
you might be a designer you might be
somebody that loves operations
you might be somebody that's a really
good mother or father to your children
you might be someone that's a really
good civil engagement
citizen there are all of these different
combinations of infinity
expressing itself via us into these
dreamed creation designs
but in order for you to know your true
nature in order for you to know
metaphysical truth
this is the portal this is
it you portal
from the finite egoic contracted
mind via this very simple juxtaposition
to the eternal shared witness
observer god
that is our true nature that's how you
portal from the mind to awareness
that simple juxtaposition that simple
portal
and in the enlightenment mystic
traditions what is said is that
you get little glimpses you get little
tastes of this in the
gradual and sudden realizations
that then make it so that the light bulb
flickers and you're like oh i just
tasted that oh
it's staying more it's like you're doing
reps
in the gym and you're working out that
over time what happens is that the light
bulb stays
on because you end up as is said by
ramana maharshi with atma vichara what
that means is self-inquiry which is
the over and over and over again going
inward to awareness
and recognizing awareness is what is
shared it is eternal it
is god it answers the question what is i
which is why the greeks wrote know
thyself on the top of the temple of
apollo at delphi 2
500 years ago it means know yourself as
infinity expressing itself know yourself
as the same
shared eternal witness observer god
pupil that has been here that will
continue
being here it's eternal and this is but
one
dreamed creation design and you have
this one unique beautiful artistic iris
of expression into it
quiet is what enables
the subtlety quiet
is what enables the cessation
of the fluctuations of mind
and that's why 2000 years ago patanjali
the yoga sutras of patanjali
he wrote yogas chitta vritti
nirodha yoga or union with god with the
absolute with the ultimate
is simply the stopping of the
fluctuations
of mind quiet the waves
of the mind and the more that you quiet
the waves of this contracted finite
entity that is
obsessed with every single cloud every
single
experience thought emotion perception
belief
sensation of object and is just
so immersed and engrossed in those that
it's completely forgotten it's eternal
it's infinitude
you quiet that down you quiet down those
clouds
use the breath
this beautiful agent of breath that is
always
with us that's what's meant by prana
it's the life force it's the life energy
it is the beautiful
dualistic yin yang that is right here
the inhalation
and the exhalation and you can use that
to quiet your mind
you can use that to take a moment
to pause don't react right away
to clouds reaction reaction this is what
the buddha taught
don't react right away to clouds rather
use your breath as a catalyst
to create distance from reacting to the
cloud
and in that process what you do is you
regain your sovereignty
you regain your supreme authority
in that process you create more and more
of a pause more and more of a
juxtaposition
and you recognize more and more of the
sky you create
more and more of the turn inward like in
the parable of the prodigal son you
create
more and more of the turn inward to
investigate consciousness to investigate
awareness itself and in doing so
you recognize that you are the sky
quieting the mind creates the subtlety
for you to recognize yourself as the
eternal
shared sky that is being colored by
all of these infinite modulations of
clouds
of music of words
of art and in the modern analogy
the easiest way to think about it is the
phone screen
we are all the screen that is god that
is the witness that is the observer
that is eternally being colored by
all of the modulations of social apps
and messages and phone calls and
calendar
in the web and all of that
and you would ask yourself well how
close is the screen to the image
how close is the sky to the cloud they
are one
there's no separation between them but
we create
this story of juxtaposition
between the clouds and the sky so that
people can more easily turn
inward and portal into that eternal
infinite awareness
if you've never tasted your eternity if
you've never tasted your infinitude
this is so critical this is your true
metaphysical nature
this is the most important thing that
you can dedicate yourself full time to
do
because what happens is you end up like
lao tzu said
in the dow to ching with wu way what
happens is you create an
effortless action butterfly effect going
outward once you come to these
realizations where your family your
friends your community people online
your co-workers
are all affected by your peace and your
happiness
you no longer try to extract peace and
happiness
from the world but rather you bring your
eternal peace and happiness
to the world that's why
as ramana maharshi said the most
important service that you can render
humanity is your god realization
recognizing the diamond necklace that's
already around your neck
and purifying it purifying it over time
the more that you recognize these
aphorisms the more that you recognize
these perennial wisdoms across
traditions the more that you
rather than cling and attach
and avert away from these clouds of
experience
and the more that you create the
juxtaposition that gives you the ability
to regain your supreme authority your
sovereignty
the more that you can bring peace and
bliss
and awe and childlike laughter
to the dreamed creation
to all of your family friends co-workers
people online
all of that your community the world
that's why it is
the most important service that you can
render humanity
and generally speaking in
the neo-advice tradition what is being
communicated is the single
direct step to
absolute realization now that
is more unstable compared to this
two-step
that we're going through right now which
bentino massaro has been a massive
influence as well
on us understanding that the two-step is
much more
stable so what we mean by the two step
is that
when you quiet your mind it enables the
subtlety
for you to step one recognize yourself
as the eternal
shared awareness that is experiencing
the infinite dreams so that's
first so you are the eternal shared
awareness
experiencing the infinite dreams that is
first that shared eternal awareness
is the pupil that is the pupil and the
iris is your unique
coloration your unique expression of the
infinite in these
infinite dreams that we experience
so that's step number one now step
number two
is the absolute realization which is to
recognize that
even the eternal observer even the pupil
itself
is dreamed even the pupil
itself is an
agent of infinity
the agent is dreamed the agent is not
what it appears to be it is illusory in
itself
as well you are not
real you are not in some
sort of a physicalism world
these are modulations of underlying
energy
even quantum mechanics in the last
hundred years has proven this as well
there are infinite amounts of
fluctuations of
emptiness of energy that then give rise
to the appearance
of form and matter and this
is one of those appearances
so even you as an agent are dreamed
just like the creation design is that's
the absolute realization that's the
second step
and you can tell that if you're an egoic
finite contracted entity that is solely
experiencing clouds
and you try and jump to the absolute
realization
that is a lot less stable because you've
done less repetitions
it's that simple to do the
repetitions is to recognize yourself as
the god rely state of the eternal shared
sky
of awareness first and then to pluck
that last thorn of even the awareness
out in the absolute
realization
and as we mentioned a moment ago even
quantum mechanically speaking all is
infinite energetic modulation
emptiness appearing as this
so simply this
is a energetic appearance
of emptiness as form
and as matter and as these dreamed
agents pupils and irises
so you have this unknowable immediacy
this immediacy
the mysterianism the unknowability
of it is it it is so beautiful
it's so awe driving and inspiring
and yet simultaneously we carry this
beautiful
inquisitive process in terms
of understanding our true
nature as that absolute expressing
itself and
like a thousand years ago we did not
understand
the fundamental unit biologically
speaking of the cell
and we did not understand the code of
life until
just 1953 so you gain
more and more of the recognition
of how the emptiness is appearing as
form and as
matter as the cells as this code of life
and what happens is that you gain more
and more sovereignty
we gain more and more of a supreme
authority
over how to maximize our planetary
prosperity
and that's so exciting so it's balancing
the mystery
with also balancing becoming the most
supreme authorities over the dream
creation design itself
because we are the investigators
of how that emptiness appears as form
and we are the ones that get to become
the gods that are tweaking the code of
life
we get to be the gods that create the
artificial general intelligence
the ones that get to create the virtual
realities that are indistinguishable the
neural links
all of these technologies but we have to
bring
the highest morality and the highest
ethics
and that's a natural process once we hit
infinity once we hit the god realized
state
the eternal shared observer that is how
outward the expression becomes
effortless
because i recognize that we all share
our being as that infinitude and we
would never
commit a malevolence on anybody at that
point
so in the non-dual tradition is talked
about without a center of experience
so there's no more agent it becomes
centerless
you as an agent have even understood
yourself to be dreamed
so now there is just this
centerless appearance
happening
and so there's the beauty of being able
to recognize that
non-dual wisdom while also recognizing
that
ah well simultaneously
i am this dreamed agent of the infinite
that is expressing itself in this dream
creation design
and so i'm excited about that process
it's a fun process
i get to be this atlas unit that is
running the simulation enlightenment
media company
and you get to be your unique unit that
is doing its own unique expression
of the infinite into this dream creation
design so it's the simultaneity
being able to hold it all across all of
these layers
at the same time that's what's known as
the non-dual
dual individuation ultimately it's the
non-duality
and in the dualistic concession is where
there's ignorance and there's knowledge
and that's where you get to turn inward
towards the diamond necklace already
around your neck
away from the egoic contracted finite
entity towards
eternity towards infinity towards god
realization
and you get the unique individuation as
well
you have to go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure cause of
delight
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure cause of
delight
and so again the portal is to go
beyond mind mind is the clouds
if you're stuck in the clouds you've got
to quiet
your mind learn how to use the breath
if you're not able to do what i just did
where you can go from being
a little bit more energetic to being
less energetic and more peaceful like
this and to slow yourself down
then you have to practice that in order
to be able to quiet your mind to see
that the clouds are
finite modulations
and that what is eternal is the
awareness
where the clouds happen the sky
in which the clouds occur
and so you portal beyond the mind by
quieting down those clouds
into this eternal sky of awareness
that's the critical first portal you
stabilize the god realization you
stabilize
enlightenment and then you weave
the peace and happiness in the tantric
tradition
into society that's what's known as
sahaja
samadhi as ramana maharshi said or as
buddha said the middle way the middle
path
where you can think about it like the
goldilocks zone very similar to how
planet earth
and its orbit around its star is in the
perfect goldilocks location
so you gain these god realized states of
enlightenment
and then you weave out the peace and
happiness into the social fabric
and then in the very last absolute
realization
you pluck even the thorn the last one
of awareness itself you recognize that
the
awareness is the agent of infinity
and that as you pluck even the last
thorn of awareness out
that's where the absolute realization is
and so that's why it's important to
follow a two-step
process where you portal from the mind
to
awareness that is eternal shared
and then you go to the next second step
of the absolute realization where you
pluck
even the witness the observer that is
eternal and shared
out as the last thorn
so this is the non-dual absolute this is
it this is the ineffable this is it
this is the ineffable this is the
ultimate this
is the absolute appearing
once you gain that realization the
relaxation of the contracted finite
egoic biological entity
just melts it just dissolves and you
expand
and you relax and it feels fantastic
because you know yourself as that
infinite peace and happiness and now you
bring that
to the dream to creation design rather
than trying to extract it
via substances and relationships and
experiences
you will never find happiness and peace
externally in the appearance of form
you must find it internally as the
infinite expressing itself
and this is the anarchic creative dream
imagine all of the different
possibilities
of musical notes that come together
to form a song this is but
one of the anarchic creative
coming together of musical notes
to create a song of a dream creation
design
when you go to sleep at night a third of
our lives
and you dream and you simulate out these
realities where you immerse yourself as
an
observer in those dream simulations at
night
how many different combinations of
dreams are possible for you at night
infinite and that's the same thing as
this
infinite possibilities of music infinite
possibilities
of art how many different ways can you
paint on a canvas
with different colors with different
strokes how many
that's what this is this is a unique
painting where you have a very specific
civilizational history
that has gotten us to where we are with
the specific earth orbiting the specific
star
and it's beautiful but it's just one
modulation of the underlying energy
and to recognize that is to recognize
yourself as infinity as eternity in this
being one expression of that
each of us are these unique units
that are doing our unique expression of
the
infinite and to know yourself as that
is enlightenment rather than being the
contracted egoic finite entity seeking
peace and happiness in the appearance of
form
what if you were wearing eternal peace
and happiness
around your neck and you didn't even
know it
that's what rumi meant by you go from
room to room looking for the diamond
necklace
that is already around your neck
awareness that is shared in eternal is
the diamond necklace around our neck
this is the absolute this is the
ineffable
and the source light refracts a very
unique
creative expression which is your iris
into the stream creation design
intelligent infinity will never come to
an
end
infinity expressing itself will never
cease exploration
you can never come to the last
combination of musical notes being
played in a song
you can never come to the last
painting on a canvas you can never come
to the last
sculpture that you carve out of marble
you can never come to the last
modulation of
underlying energy that appears as form
and matter
you can never come to the last
irises the last expressions
of these dreamed
agents these dreamed individuals
these dreamed creative expressions of
the infinite
you can never come to the end of all of
these possibilities
of identity you can never come to the
end of that
and you and i are but combinations
of that expression of infinity
and that's why we say welcome to
simulation
the eternal infinite simulation
know yourself as
that and weave the peace and happiness
that comes from that knowledge
being a gnostic being into
society and that's why
t.s eliot has the very famous
we shall not cease from exploration
and the end of all our exploring
will be to arrive where we started
and know the place for the first
time
we will never end our exploration we
will never
end infinity expressing itself
and as we turn inward and
recognize our own infiniti
we recognize for the first time over
and over and over again our
own true nature that's why it's called
lila in sanskrit it's the divine
play the cosmic play
that is infinite it's eternal
we are sent out as agents of infinity
just to be able to turn back in a game
of hide and seek
outward in the hide inward with the seek
and boom
over and over and over again we
realize the one infinite creator
and then we effortlessly express
ourselves with the highest morality
outward
in architecting the maximal planetary
prosperity
in the streamed creation design
so that's the portal between mind and
awareness again
quiet the mind and gain the subtlety
to be able to recognize that the clouds
appear
in the eternal shared sky that's the
pupil
and then to recognize that even
that god realized state of the infinite
eternal
shared observer witness is
a dreamed agent of the absolute
and when you pluck out even that last
thorn that is the absolute realization
and so it's all about subtlety it's all
about recognizing that there
is this portal that this portal is a
real thing
between the incessant fluctuations
of mind of the egoic contracted finite
energy of the entity of the egoic
consciousness
and as it portals into the infinite
eternal shared awareness that
it relaxes it expands
that contracted energy dissolves and it
you feel the eternal bliss and peace
and then you bring that peace and
happiness
to society effortlessly
your friends your families co-workers
people online
community the world and again that's why
the greatest service you can render
humanity is
to god realize recognize yourself as the
eternal
shared awareness that you already wear
as the diamond around your neck
recognize it and express
yourself as that source light refracts
through the uniqueness of that jewel
most harmonically outward in
architecting maximal planetary
prosperity
adore you thank you so much for tuning
in if the video brought you value like
the video if you haven't yet subscribed
to the channel please
also leave a comment below with how you
feel would love to hear from you
share the video with people you know
this would make a profound positive
impact on please
and if you'd like to you can join the
channel and our membership
gain exclusive perks and every single
last dollar goes directly back into the
execution of all of our projects
infinite adoration infinite love thank
you
so so much
you